hey thanks for saying
however you would say that and then like
I think
so we'll do the python verses
[Music]
hello Thomas I fella great to be here
how's it going very well it's such a
great honor to get to finally meet you I
feel like so much of our engagements
have been virtually through our and
Pharma and uh I feel like I know you but
I haven't actually got to meet you so
this is nice it's good to finally sit
down for sure you have such a
fascinating background of coming into
the pharmaceutical drug development
space and working with Legacy software
and moving into open source and creating
Admiral one of the most important
packages of of the entire late stage
clinical trials process and doing such
an important part of of working with
data which is critical it'd be great to
learn more about what was that Journey
like for you to get there yeah in many
ways it started by accident I never
thought I would for starters work in
Farmer and definitely become a
programmer and so I ventured into sports
science because I was in love with
sports all my life and that's really I
was passionate about and then got a job
in my I think fourth semester of my
undergraduate working at a research lab
in the University Hospital in Berlin
where I'm from and there we had a PhD
student who had written our code he was
quite proficient at that
and I collected some data with a certain
measurement device which would produce
an XML output which as you might imagine
is not easily analyzable so he wrote a
script to basically turn it into a nice
tidy data frame
and I was supposed to run that so he
gave it to me and said install R in our
studio and then click the source button
sort of and
way over my head didn't work for
starters so I had to kind of dig down a
bit and make this work and at some point
when I managed to run the script see the
output I thought like okay this is
pretty powerful so this became a huge
passion and yeah later on when I decided
to
join the pharmaceutical industry
basically I looked for an intersection
between working on clinical trials and
programming and then I found the role of
statistical programmer
it's such an amazing journey and it
speaks to so many of the people in the
pharmaceutical industry as they're
transitioning to open source and I think
what's also really exciting about what
you did is you came to R for a use case
at work and fast forward only a few
years you create a very popular package
for creating Graphics obviously with
open source what you really want to do
is create something which others can
also use because when you face a some a
problem most likely someone else faces
the same issue or even let's say similar
so it makes sense to say I created this
it's probably useful stuff for someone
else so let's make it open source and
that's what I did with this package
called GG charts which kind of tried to
make it easier to create certain plots
which tended to be code heavy with
ggplot too and make it basically a
function call to create for example like
a sort of a bar chart which I thought
was should be something very simple but
turned out to be quite an exercise
likely to do so you take and create a
package and what's to me such an awesome
thing is that
you were taking deep plier workflows and
piping of data into ggplot2 and you said
yourself gosh I can simplify even this
which wasn't very much a simplification
of various workflows
um tell us about the motivation to
simplify the interface into programming
and helping people do such core things
as graphics
yeah really what you when you develop
software what you want to do is create
as easy as possible of an interface
while providing as much power in a way
as possible so you can create very
powerful tools which are hard to use and
no one will ever use them so instead
what you should opt for is Simplicity
and that people can adopt it and that
they are empowered than to to readily
adopt it so that was kind of what I was
aiming for make something that looked
kind of hard with the existing tools and
try to streamline it and make it very
easy so if you want to create a certain
type of graph you just have a single
function call with a couple of
meaningfully named arguments and then
off you go
and then on to crayon was that was that
a big day for you for sure definitely
yeah I mean yeah that was a big day and
I'm pretty sure I did a post and
celebrated it so yeah absolutely and so
take that into the work that you've done
on Admiral is there Lessons Learned From
that package and the Simplicity around
the interface and creating Graphics that
you create around this interfacing for
atom data sets I mean yeah I think
certainly the aspect of trying to keep
it as simple as possible for the user
that's a big one which we had with kind
of developing admill for atom data sets
yeah because the existing solution we
had
um which was not an R which was in
proprietary language in many ways
um could be hard to use for people so as
long as totally we were you know in the
realm of standard data sets and it just
worked it's good but then if something
fails or you need to customize and
sublect box and people struggle with it
yeah so we wanted to have something that
is extremely simple to use for people
just have to read the documentation once
and then I'll show okay if I need to do
this I use this function if I need to do
this I use the other function yeah so
Simplicity was really really key
one area that's so interesting is this
idea of Admiral being extended by other
groups and people and pharmaceutical
companies into different areas of
Pharma and Life Sciences right vaccines
oncology
what makes it about this use case that
extends it well into these other areas
of atom data creation why not just use
Admiral or why not just use D plier
well I think certainly you could use
deep plier and that's certainly what we
do it's the basis of what we use we kind
of say the Tidy versus grades let's you
know take that as our basis and build on
top of it but it's obviously streamlines
a lot as you said because there's common
algorithms you do in these kind of
derivations which are specific to this
domain so you can take all these deep
layer functions put them together and do
that thing but it's much easier if we
give you a single function to do that
and the idea of Admiral is we built like
the core layer all the stuff that anyone
would need for kind of general purpose
let's call it analysis data sets in
Farmer for clinical trials but then
there's the all these intricacies of
whether you're working on oncology or on
vaccine development or any other
therapeutic area and I don't have the
expertise for that but if there's a
certain company which is heavily
investing in kind of research and
development on that kind of front they
are the experts so it makes sense that
they say you know what you've built is
good we'll take that as sort of the next
basis of the pyramid so to speak and
build again on top of it and that worked
out well so fall with these three
extensions and I really hope that this
kind of ecosystem flourishes and gets
larger and larger do you think that
there will be more
unification or standardization of other
areas of the late stage clinical work I
would certainly hope so because at the
end of the day we all do the same work
so there is this submission package if
you want to file for your new drug to
the FDA for example and for all of us
whether you're working at a Roche GSK or
Pfizer at the end of the day it's the
same so why make it kind of different
use different tools and spend the effort
of you know within each company to build
such a tool that's kind of what we did
in the last 20 years and now there's
this nice shift to say we'll adopt open
source and we'll also as I said embrace
the mindset and then you know we can
just bundle the resources and say we all
face the common problem let's get
together and solve it together in a way
that we all can actually use it and that
way ambitron benefits
not only do you have this fantastic team
but you also have a great focus on
building out the infrastructure and
tooling and
um Kieran was talking about in the
webinar that shiny was the spark that
helped focus on the creation of teal and
you have other Frameworks like ocean
tell me more about that and that that
view of creating tooling internally to
help with the creation of content and
process right so you mentioned teal and
that's kind of an interesting case
because you know when you say well stop
doing way uh things the way we did for
20 years we kind of do it different now
everyone says like why should we it
works right but when you show people
something like shiny which is something
that we didn't have previously as like a
solution then people somehow get excited
they see like this adds value and so in
many ways that was like the initial foot
in the door and then once that got
adopted readily you know we went on to
say okay what are other things where we
could leverage are in open source and
then you know Admiral Oak these other
things got developed but all these tools
are
quote unquote useless unless you have
sort of a platform that all packages
together and you know farmer being a
fairly regulated environment you need to
make sure that you know the analysis you
do are done in kind of a kind of what we
call validated environment basically you
need to make sure that the software use
is reasonably reliable for what you do
and
you know to be fair um that makes sense
because imagine you do an error on your
analysis to get a drug approved which
then turns out to not be beneficial but
potentially even harmful so you got to
make sure that everything kind of works
and you need that kind of base layer the
Computing environment in which you can
do that and so that's the work that has
been done with ocean led by Ian Healy
within rosh which is a huge undertaking
to basically say
build a novel environment to really
embrace all this open source and it's
not only about R there's python in there
there can be Julia in there it's kind of
really based on all these great open
source things like for example Docker
containerization so really taking all
this Cutting Edge development and making
sure that we can use that within a kind
of our drug development space
in other interviews and in the community
you're a big advocate of using the
rstudio IDE and tell people about the
our studio products as part of those
environments at Roche sure so if you
spin up basically in our container in
this ocean environment you have
basically an rstudio server Pro instance
ready for you and I can still remember
going back to that initial art script I
got I downloaded our opened the kind of
argui that comes with it yeah that
wasn't too exciting and then getting to
something like our studio which really
you know
um so much streamlines you work and you
get all these nice tools and your
development just becomes more efficient
you can actually Focus
um on kind of the hard things to design
and stuff and have all these little bits
and pieces that help you along the way
and looking back at your career just a
couple years ago you listed shiny and
projects that worked in shiny
um what is it like to publish shiny
applications internally at Rouge to
posit connect and in are there other
types of content there like apis and
things that that you use in the clinical
process yeah so when we develop these
teal applications internally we
obviously want to make sure that our
stakeholders who want to use them have
readily access to that and
um kind of you know data scientists are
not kind of devops people or I.T people
they don't know how to pull up a server
I certainly don't and I'm sure that many
don't even want to bother about that
they want to build the app and then they
want to click a button and say okay now
it's available to these group of people
and it's kind of great to have like a
product as kind of positive connect
which yeah streamlines this for you and
then it works and you can concentrate on
kind of your expertise which is to make
sure that the actual application that is
built is fit for purpose for your
clinician for your safety scientist
whoever wants to use it again
one of the key things right now that the
industry is focused on and I feel like
other pharmaceutical companies are
looking at Roche is the buzz around next
year in the upcoming years of doing
submissions fully in are and there's
been some pilot work done around that
but I believe rosh has been the key
organization that says we're going after
that what's that been like internally as
you prepare for that
obviously a huge challenge because
we made the decision to say every new
study starting this year 2023 should go
on our new platform with ocean and use
all these next-gen tools like Admiral
Oak teal and Etc to deliver their
studies and you know we cannot influence
whether or not a study reads out
positively in the end but if it does
that basically means it's time for that
submission which uses R and open source
as its backbone and will get submitted
to a health authority and actually
there's one phase three trial we have in
oncology which is already on our
platform since last year they were kind
of early adopters gotten ready to be
able to do this and they are planned to
read out their study by the end of this
year so even potentially you know
December November of this year 2023 so
there could be a kind of first clinical
trial submission using all these tools
in R to the FDA and which is huge and
obviously that puts a lot of pressure
not only on the people working on that
particular study because everyone is
looking at them but also people like me
building tools because they feel the
pressure of if our tools don't are not
up for the job then they will fail in a
way
um and everyone within the organization
is I would say laser focused on making
sure that
we achieve this goal
um and it's really interesting to see I
mean there's so many great developers
within Roche and all converging on this
kind of one goal and trying to make it
work it's very interesting because if
you look at new drug applications on the
FDA Side open source and R has been used
for quite some time I think I've even
found submissions as far back as 2007
where R has been used in people and even
organizations are starting to use python
in some of these submissions and so
there is this interest of
interoptability and and moving to a
world where open source languages can
work together and you see an area like
pkpd there's a lot of tooling use there
for modeling and simulations and
non-linear mixed effects models and
things like that how much of the future
do you see teal and these Frameworks
that you have evolving to include other
language as part of these submissions
an interesting question and I think it's
hard to say really but the way we for
example build this ocean platform is to
say let's make it language agnostic in a
way let's not repeat the quote-unquote
error we had 20 years ago to log in into
a single tools deck but build something
that is extensible such that if in the
future for example Julia is very
interesting for PK you mentioned
um
if people want to use that they should
be able to we should
Empower them in a way to use whatever
tool they feel is best for the job and I
think that's that's kind of a critical
shift in mindset to say
we have a tool and we need to make it
work for use case X but instead say we
have use case X which of all these tools
out there is the best for the job and
then enabling people to say this is the
best one let's take it and let's bring
it into production so to speak
and there seems to be such an obsession
in our industry and rightfully so around
validation or should I say qualification
and reproducibility right do you see
this being
built out further into different
infrastructures tooling technology what
do you think the next two to three years
of that space will be so I hope that
within three to five years what you
mentioned again we have a convergence on
that and I think that's already starting
to happen because there is this R
validation Hub which is again lots of
farmer companies coming together and
trying to tackle that problem together
and there are thoughts around having a
cran-like repository for quote-unquote
validated packages for clinical trial
data so people are very much aware that
this is a problem we really only get to
tackle efficiently if we again work
together because
if we have again a validation approach
in at Roche at GSK at jnj that's
probably not the best approach so I
really hope that again just as we had on
the code development side we can come
together and make something work out
there but it certainly seems to be going
into that direction which is good to see
about going in New Directions do you
think the world ever be a python package
in the Pharma verse or some other
that's an interesting question
um I wouldn't say no because you never
know what the future brings I think now
that we have shown that one particular
open source language is viable why
shouldn't another not be viable as well
that being said I think there's a reason
why R is particularly interesting for
the pharmaceutical space because if you
think about it the kinds of analyzes
that we do in terms of a primary
endpoint of a study that's really the
kind of classical biostatistics often
also frequentest kind of way of
analyzing data and really
um R is built just for that it's a
language for statistical Computing and
while python may offer that to some
extent as well it's really another Beast
it's a general purpose language
that being said it certainly has
attracted a lot of data scientists
particularly in the kind of ML and AI
space and that is also coming to Farmer
as well but it's not the kind of bread
and butter work of showing with a
clinical trial that this particular drug
actually works it's more like on the
periphery I would say so there are use
cases for sure
um
would someone say Port Admiral to python
maybe but I'm not sure it's worth the
effort Thomas I can't tell you how much
I've enjoyed this I've uh the fact that
we're actually able to hang out and chat
is much better than uh engaging in
emails or virtually through our informa
it was a pleasure thank you so much
thanks Thomas
[Music]
foreign